if i was to think about leaders of the
future actually their ability to stand
up and say i don't know i got it wrong
or i've changed my mind those three
things are really in the forefront of my
mind because when you're navigating
through uncertainty you're going to get
it wrong sometimes and that's okay but
it's the deliberate part have you sat
down and deliberately now changed your
mind hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning in this week's episode of
deep dive i sit down with dr grace
lordon grace is an associate professor
in behavioral science at the london
school of economics an expert advisor to
the uk government as a member of the
skills and productivity board and her
academic writings have been published in
international academic journals earlier
this year grace published her book think
big take small steps and build the
future you want if i were to be a doctor
if i were to be a trader what would be
the tasks that i would be doing on a
day-to-day basis and would i ultimately
end up enjoying those tasks in the
conversation we deep dive into grace's
book and tons of behavioral science
concepts including how our emotions
influence decision making the
relationship between gender and risk
aversion why we procrastinate in our
fear of failure the one thing about
human beings is that we're really good
actually at rebounding
so when we go through negative
experience and we allow ourselves to go
through negative experiences we realize
actually it's not as bad as i thought
there are other options later and we
tend to be very very resilient and when
we're anticipating failure or
anticipating losses we underestimate
that resilience so please feel free to
grab a cup of tea and enjoy the
conversation dr lorden thank you very
much for coming on the show you've
written this book think big um which is
extremely good uh i finished it on
audible this morning and we were talking
about yeah your kind of woes with
recording the audiobook uh which is very
good like i i thought the way you were
narrating it it was very like expressive
um a lot of the audiobooks i listened to
are usually fantasy fiction it's a very
like non-expressive narrator but so i i
could really hear the passion that was
coming coming through in your voice as
you were as you were writing it i did
some drama classes as a kid so i think
that they came into good use for the
first time ever since i've left school
that's very handy um yeah so lots of
stuff i want to talk about in the book
before we get started you are apparently
on the government advisory body for
productivity and skills which is very
cool um what does what does that mean
and how did how does one get into the
government advisory body for
productivity it's a great question
actually so it sits under the um
secretary of state um reporting into
boris um and it's part of the leveling
up strategy and the idea is really to
think about skills of the future and how
they will be delivered um in the uk so
um boris has come out and basically said
that he doesn't think education should
just be about secondary school and
should just be about young people going
to university anymore it should be that
you get to go to university when you're
25 35 45
and i guess part of our job is really
thinking about how those skills can
actually be delivered and looking to see
actually given what we have already
whether or not there's some people who
are doing better than others and
delivering skills
okay like so how how did you how did you
get this job did they like does the
government email you does someone knock
on your door how does that work this was
an open competition so they basically
advertised they asked for things like
you know backgrounds and economics
backgrounds and labor um and i think
from their perspective my background in
economics coupled with the behavioral um
science stuff and actually having
written the book on kind of thinking
about careers from an individual
perspective was quite appealing so we've
ended up being um we're six people six
experts on the committee one person's an
education specialist four traditional
economists and then there's kind of me
who fits between the kind of behavioral
economics mold okay yeah so you're an
associate professor of behavioral
sciences at lse is that right um
well one thing that intrigued me as i
was reading about uh in reading about
your background like i i wouldn't have
thought that behavioral sciences in
terms of like you know time management
and productivity and procrastination
some of the stuff you talk about in the
book that feels to me as like a lay
person that has nothing to not quite fit
within economics so like how how does
how does behavioral science fit into
economics as a field
so i mean if you think about the simple
um lesson that you might learn if you if
you take an economics class we learned
that when people are making decisions
they weigh up the cost the benefits and
the risk and i know you have a medical
background so you can appreciate that if
someone is choosing to have a big mac
today that you might necessarily believe
that they're weighing up the cost in 10
years time and the second big mac the
next day and the third big mac and
that's really where i kind of come from
is thinking how do people actually make
decisions but how can we tweak that
model to really understand human
decision making um in a much better way
than economists do
and in a way that's actually useful for
policy makers which i think that a lot
of psychologists failed so i kind of put
myself in the center where
we want to be able to advise government
i want to be able to advise firms and
what they should actually do to make
people happier more productive whatever
is their goal in a particular moment and
to do that we fundamentally need to
understand um decision making and the
second thing that's really important to
understand is the intent action gap so
why is it that i as grace would say i
will do things today but very often
don't end up doing them and you know
whether we talk about education you know
people who enter education often don't
study as much as they should um people
often choose courses that are
particularly bad for them even though
they say that they might actually um go
another path so again it's really
getting down to the nitty-gritty of how
can we alter decision-making
in a way that's not paternalistic
but is giving people information to help
them go in the right direction hmm okay
yeah the intent action gap i i think
like we've all felt that in our lives
like multiple times a day as i was
reading this i started listening to your
book about four or five days ago and the
very first chapter talks about this idea
of me plus um i wonder if you're gonna
like elaborate like what does what does
meat plus mean
so if you i mean if you go back to the
economics we're really good i think at
making at helping ourselves in the
present day so we know what makes us
happy in the moment but very often the
things that we have to invest in to give
our future selves a better future we
don't often do so what i like people to
do is to think about where would they
like to be if it all worked out so if
they threw out you know lost aversion if
they threw out fear of failure where
will they actually end up being and have
that be their me plus but before they
commit to that being their me plus
really think about what will that me
plus actually do because i've noticed a
lot of times when i talk to people about
careers they're attached to a label so
they want to be a trader or an
investment banker or they want to be a
doctor
or they're attached to a lifestyle so
they want to be able to go on a
particular vacation or buy a particular
car and kind of think big journey is
really thinking about if i were to be a
doctor if i were to be a trader what
would be the tasks that i would be doing
on a day-to-day basis and would i
ultimately end up enjoying those tasks
so the activities that i'm going to
spend the time in
and there's two reasons for that so one
it makes you happier to actually do
tasks that you like which feels like a
no-brainer but secondly if you're
engaged in tasks that you like you tend
to be more successful and it's the
second that i'm really interested in and
kind of getting people into jobs where
they feel that they've reached the
success that they want okay
interesting and do you think
when it comes to being engaged in tasks
that you like some people say it's a
case of
find the thing that fits within your
values your personality and when once
you find that thing then you'll find it
fun and then there's another school of
thought that says well you know the
whole finding something that you're
passionate about is actually kind of
hard to do so
think about the stuff that you're
actually doing and find ways to make it
more interesting for yourself uh how how
do you feel about those two different
different camps i don't really feel that
they're different so you know
so so people are claiming now that they
choose companies based on the values the
companies might have
and i think that's true in the same way
that we choose a company based on a
salary but when you're actually in the
job what tends to matter with respect to
productivity and happiness is how you
feel in those tasks in that moment and
if i'm working for a company that's
saving the environment but i've been
treated really badly in a microculture
in order to save that environment
there's a couple of companies come to
mind when i think about that um then i'm
not going to be productive and i'm not
going to be happy i'm actually likely to
leave that that job so it's more about
going beyond thinking what is the
company's mission what is my personality
and what is the micro culture of the
team that i'm going to be working in and
will that make me happy will i be
connected to the mission because my team
is connected to the mission
it's very hard to assess in advance when
you're applying for a job it's really
hard it is it's really really hard and i
think then if you bring it down to the
tasks and asking at an interview what
will i be doing on a day-to-day basis
um so when i come to work for you ali
what would i be doing on a day-to-day
basis as part of your team um so if you
can imagine me on a monday how will i
spend my time
the fact that you as a manager have
taught about that first they will tell
me that you're a good manager because
you'll know actually what you want the
person to do um and you're not just
hiring blindly but the second is having
that information allows me to make my
mind up because if the if i like the
tasks i'm probably going to like the
team okay yeah that's very interesting
so that was a big part of the message i
took away from the me pluster and the
way it it manifested in my life when i
read it i was i was thinking okay you
know let's engage with this like what's
what's kind of what does me plus look
like and initially i was thinking oh you
know i'd really like to have six-pack
abs and then i came across a bit where
you were like
forget about that focus on like what
what did the tasks look like and i was
like okay you know what what i want me
plus to do is to be able to exercise
every day and to have fun doing it yeah
um and so for the last four days i've
actually been to the gym i went to a
yoga class yesterday morning i did a
workout at like 8am this morning and i
i've never really done this sort of
thing but i was like excited about that
i i was excited that the end goal was
not six plus six-pack abs i was excited
that the end goal was that in a way
there wasn't an end goal and it was a
case of just i want to be able to enjoy
this um
is that the sort of thing that you get a
lot when you're doing this sort of
research that process rather than
outcome kind of thing so i kind of write
a lot for kind of people who might not
have made it yes or people who have
plateaued so if you if you take the
exercising analogy from somebody who's
contemplating doing the kind of a 5k run
rather than somebody who is
contemplating doing the london marathon
and is really well placed for that
and i think for the person who hasn't
done exercise for a while or the person
who hasn't really invested in their
career for a while the worst thing they
can do is do too much so if you hadn't
invested for a while the worst thing you
could do is go to the gym for three
hours you might get through it today but
the chances of repeating that are really
really small and i think kind of the one
of the big powerful messages on july
anything big is whether you're focused
on your health or whether you're focused
on your career it's those small actions
that you take today will determine
yourself in two years time three years
time in four years time and actually by
throwing out the idea that you're going
to reinvent yourself in 30 days is
really really powerful because you're
much more likely to stick to it you know
you can accomplish an extraordinary
amount in 12 months very little in you
know 12 minutes or you know a very short
period of time you know i've been making
videos semi-themed around productivity
for the last four years and a big chunk
of the advice boils down to
consistency and just showing up and
taking small actions repeatedly and in a
way not really worrying so much about
the ultimate goal
um and these days i teach i uh teach
courses helping people become like
youtubers and stuff and and the way you
become a successful youtuber is you just
make one or two videos every week for
the next like five years um but no one
sticks with it for that long because
they have like the oh i must hit a
certain subscriber count i must hear a
certain like view count and
my view on this is that having like in a
way those outcome metrics the ones that
are outside of our control are kind of
unhelpful especially at the start of a
journey do you have any thoughts on on
that point well when you were talking it
actually reminded me i watched a video
of yours on compounding so when people
are choosing to invest
we accept compounding very very easily
right so we accept the idea actually
that you know if we leave money in for a
very long period of time it's going to
compound so we're probably going to be
okay in our pensions and it's exactly
the same here when it comes to your
career like those very small things that
you're going to do today and i ask for a
commitment of 90 minutes a week which
for most people regardless of how
pressurized you feel is very very
possible um that should compound once
you do once you've chosen tasks that
align with your me plus
relatively quickly okay 90 minutes a
week that's like 13 minutes a day
day-ish yes very doable
um one one bit that i was gonna ask you
about that i i thought maybe i disagreed
with was you talk like the title of the
book is think big yeah and the vibe i
got from the chapter around goals is
that you're keen on people setting
or
perhaps not but like
one camp of people in the sphere is
encouraging people to set these big
hairy audacious goals
and then figuring out the small steps
taken you can you can take to get there
but then there's another camp and this
is sort of where
where i think i am whereby
i think
in a way i feel maybe setting goals is a
bit overrated because if you're setting
a goal then
you're
essentially to me that feels like a
contract to be unhappy until you hit the
goal and then you hit the goal and you
have this like fleeting sense of like oh
i hit a million subscribers cool yeah
you know my day to day hasn't really
changed et cetera et cetera so the way i
kind of think about goals is i try and
throw goals out the window and instead
just focus on those like what do i
actually want to do but i don't know if
i'm just like bsing myself and like
you're doing okay so
if that seems to be working for you i
mean i think so so for people who read
the book the goal is really there to
serve two purposes
so one so that you start investing in
your career so it helps to find the
tasks this week
and two so that you actually bring your
future self forward so you're not always
investing in activities that just serve
you in the present day but in the book i
do talk about the idea that every um
sunday so every kind of well i i pick
sunday because it's the start of my week
that you reflect on how the week
previous went and you look to see
whether or not there are new
opportunities that you should be
pivoting your goal for
so i see the think big part of the book
as really giving people a direction so
they can set off on a journey and they
start walking and more interesting
things might actually come along but
they make a conscious decision to follow
those interesting things so then they go
off on a slightly different journey so
if you take your own career for example
it was probably a great idea that you
studied medicine and cambridge right and
now you have an entirely different
career but you are using some of the
skills that you actually learned in the
university so in that particular case
you would have sat back and said
actually do i really want to pivot and
do a large pivot and the answer would
have been yes but had you never gone
into medicine
medical school maybe you would never
have started walking in this direction
and come to the destination so it's
really about movement oh okay that's
really interesting um i was having these
thoughts i was it was a few weeks ago
and i was on a date and we went we were
kind of driving around afterwards just
like chatting and i was kind of thinking
that like driving around without a
destination it's just like if it felt a
bit wrong and so i just put the
destination of the like the mcdonald's
drive through in the sat nav and it
wasn't really about the destination it
was about okay i've got a destination
now
now i know what th what what the journey
is
and when we got to the mcdonald's
drivers like what what else it's a
mcdonald's drive through like the the
destination is actually not that
important but the point is i was
thinking huh maybe having the
destination
lets you kind of set the direction for
your journey and then you can always
change your mind as you as you go
further down the line
and as humans we love certainty so even
if we've created for ourselves this is
the goal that we're moving towards then
we change our mind for the period of
time that we're moving there is
certainty one of the biggest things that
hampers people's growth and you know
stops them kind of getting to the place
where they probably deserve to be
is that they feel that the journey is
actually uncertain so by kind of having
that destination allows you to kind of
to move towards it oh okay yeah this
reminds me of advice i got when i was in
in med school where
like once you once you've done your once
you start your clinical years the
question everyone asks is oh what
specialty do you want to do and the
honest answer for the vast majority of
people is i don't freaking out i have no
idea like you know there are those odd
like weirdos that i've decided on the
age at the age of three they want to be
a neurosurgeon yeah um but for most of
us it's like honestly i don't know i
just want to kind of get a feel of
different specialties and kind of
um and the advice that one of one of the
consultants who i really respected gave
me was that look honestly just pick
something and start moving towards it
because then you will start doing things
that will build up your cv and you'll
start actually finding opportunities
your way and then if you want to change
your mind it's much easier to change
direction when you're moving forward
rather than when you when you're
stationary and you learn about yourself
as well what do i like and what do i
what do i dislike which you won't do if
you're just if you're still kind of
standing still so kind of you know did i
write about what should you do if you
have no idea what you want to do in the
future where a lot of young people are
and actually people who you know and who
are later in life and again it's really
about thinking what do i kind of like
doing now so let's do some more of that
and move towards a goal and then on the
way being really reflective am i
enjoying these tasks or am i just doing
it because i like the idea of becoming a
surgeon or becoming a lawyer or becoming
another job title and i really want
people to move away from the second you
know i kind of think with the future of
work
we have this disruption where people who
are able to
kind of pivot
know what their skills are job craft
which you might which you've mentioned
already it would really stand to them
um
yeah so it's like you're moving away
from being and more towards doing yes
being a doctor versus like what does the
day-to-day of practicing medicine
actually look like and does this sound
like the sort of thing that is my idea
of fun right now and i guess
i guess like it's it's kind of you know
there's that thing in in in the research
about it's it's hard for us to predict
what will make us happy in the future
but it's a reasonable first
approximation that the sort of stuff i
enjoy doing now like talking to people
like you or like making videos is likely
to also probably make me happy in the
future and if it doesn't then well i can
just change course yeah this is like a
great search so what what you know what
the government should have done in
covert and some governments did
incredibly well was what we call this
grid search strategy where they get new
data they update their decision making
based on the data and they're willing to
go backwards or they're willing to go
left and they're willing to go right and
always having that openness to a change
of direction and i think if we kind of
bring that into careers that you know
really we don't know our preferences
very well we've watched some tv when
we're young so depending on what you
watch that might actually ultimately
determine your career maybe you move
towards that if you have no idea but
always paying attention to am i enjoying
the tasks is it do i feel purpose if i
was doing this in five years time would
i be really really happy um and you know
my director in the lsd manuscript um she
spoke to me kind of about careers and
kind of really thinking five years ahead
of time what's your next challenge going
to be because by the time five years
comes you're not going to be able to do
that challenge unless you've spent a
decent amount of time doing activities
that makes you credible to be that
person standing in that room and really
taking that approach i think can help
people okay yeah interesting we're going
to take a very quick break to introduce
our sponsor for this episode and that is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last two plus years they're a
fantastic platform for learning maths
science and computer science with
engaging and interactive online courses
and the great thing about brilliant is
that they really teach stuff from a very
first principles based approach it's
almost like the way that we were taught
in places like oxford and cambridge
where you learn a concept and then you
apply the concept to an interesting
problem rather than just being spoon-fed
stuff like we initially learned in
school my favorite courses on brilliant
are the computer science ones as some of
you guys might know i was torn between
applying to medicine and computer
science i went for medicine in the end
but i always had an affinity to computer
science and taking the courses on
brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
you mentioned that um you often
you've written about and you and you
speak to people that have no idea at all
what they want to do how how should
someone in that position go about
figuring this out and i kind of ask
because i feel like i'm kind of in that
position right now where it's like i
have all these options in front of it i
don't really know which one to pick but
like yeah
so i think for somebody who has no idea
what they want to do and who doesn't
necessarily have options it really is
about bringing it back to
what are the activities that i would
like to do and how can i get the skills
to actually do those activities and then
going about spending time engaged in
those activities so maybe you want to do
some more public speaking you know
trying to get on panels um
trying to spend some time with people
who might be actually able to get you
into the room where you can do some
public speaking in the future
going to talks and studying what makes a
good speaker and what doesn't make a
good speaker if you really really have
really have no experience and then maybe
there are some skills that you have to
pay for and i do say in anything big for
people who do not know what they want to
do i would avoid committing to a
four-year degree or an expensive
master's program and really use the
resources that are out there that are
either cheap or free because there's so
many things that we can actually learn
now without having to set foot in into a
traditional classroom even though i work
in a university and we have wonderful
degrees i think you need to be certain
to spend spend that amount of money and
then i think for someone like you i
think doing time audits can really help
so during the week writing down what
you're actually doing which you probably
do already but writing down whether or
not you actually enjoyed doing them did
you feel firstly a sense of purpose that
it was kind of leading you to a better
place in five years time or did you feel
fun in the moment
and then if there were activities that
aren't kind of investing in you in five
years time and they're not giving you
fun at the moment consider job crafting
which i think you're in a good position
to do where you remove those activities
and do more of the things that are
giving your purpose and more the things
that are giving you fun today okay
interesting so time audit and thinking
about was this thing fun and if not was
it at least purposeful yes and if not
why the hell am i doing it yes and i
don't journal at all and i really just
put these marks next to my diary so
after the event i'll edit the calendar
and i'll say yeah i enjoyed that that
was good that's going to pay me for it
in the future as well
or actually that was really a drain of
my energy um and and let's avoid things
like that in the future one thing that i
often kind of clash with my mom about is
the idea of changing one's mind and
making
making plans and then changing and then
changing them a few weeks to months
later
um so for example
last year i had decided that you know
what at the stage my career is currently
at i'm i'm considering moving to america
to continue to practice medicine and
started gearing myself up to take those
exams and you know
made the mistake
maybe not it had a good clickbait title
of making a video called i'm moving to
america uh where i announced my plans
for like moving to america and then as i
started preparing for this exam and
realized how much work it was going to
be and then as the youtube channel
started to explode and i thought hang on
maybe this you know moving to america
you know i it will be four years of
residency
there's a reasonable a reasonable amount
of hard work maybe it'll be fun and at
the end of it you become a doctor who
makes 400k errors or something like that
but i saw i could see the trajectory of
the youtube channel being more
interesting than that point and so i
kind of pivoted and thought screw this
america thing but now anytime almost any
time i speak to someone they would have
seen that video and they're like hey i
thought you were moving to america
especially my mother your often says
that hey you know you said you were
moving to america then you changed your
mind um yeah
do you think there's
much or to what extent is there value in
picking a goal and then sticking to it
rather than just like willy-nilly
changing one's mind i don't you want to
change your mind willy-nilly so i i come
in between kind of in between you and
your mom in some ways so so i think the
first thing is you know maybe you should
do a youtube video on song cost fallacy
right and talk to people about the fact
that you know you have put yourself out
there you had this commitment devised
but actually that's the cost that you'll
have to think the embarrassment of
actually changing your mind because when
you reviewed your options and you review
them deliberately it looked like
sticking to youtube was right for you
and i think that second part is really
important to ask yourself did you review
your options and review them
deliberately kind of thinking about what
are the costs and benefits
or was it something else was it kind of
the length of the residency was it a
fear of failure was it lost aversion
that drove you to that decision and i
think if it's deliberate you absolutely
should change your mind and you know i
think one of the big powerful kind of um
influences on our decision making is our
emotions um and when we think about the
future so if you think about doing a
residency in america it does actually
sound quite scary to be honest kind of
going now you know doing four years when
you clearly have a really good career at
the moment um were you anticipating kind
of a loss that might not necessarily be
realized and not seeing gains that that
trip would actually give you and i think
if you sit down and say actually i was
deliberate then you should change your
mind and i think one of the problems in
society today is that we think that good
citizens good leaders should never
change their mind and i think in covid
that was to the detriment of many
countries because it took a lot for some
leaders to come out and say
look actually this isn't the right
strategy i'm going to now change i'm not
going to change my mind so if i was to
think about leaders of the future
actually their ability to stand up and
say i don't know i got it wrong or i've
changed my mind those three things are
really in the forefront of my mind
because when you're navigating through
uncertainty you're going to get it wrong
sometimes and that's okay but it's the
deliberate part have you sat down and
deliberately now changed your mind or is
it something you use the word
willy-nilly is it a willy-nilly kind of
reflex action and then it might be
revisiting oh interesting yeah like when
when i was following the news with all
the coveted stuff and occasionally there
would be the phrase oh the government
has made another u-turn and i would kind
of think that like
isn't it a good thing like like surely
sticking to a plan that's shown not to
be like a herd immunity or something
like you would
surely you want the government to make a
u-10 yep um why do we have such a a
weird reaction to leaders changing their
mind about stuff do you think i think
things were predictable for a long time
so you know i think as well kind of
maybe the difference in attitudes
between yourself and your mum do you
come from generational gaps she would
have been in the uk when there was a big
period of growth so we had some dips but
we haven't seen the disruption like
we've seen kind of in the last you know
um kind of five six years to people who
were early twenties now
they are facing much more uncertainty
than people would have done twenty years
ago forty years ago coming out of outer
university and i think when we're in
periods of certainty we expect people to
get it right you know good decision
making is is possible right so if i
could give you if i can if i could um
talk to you through your options in
decision making under uncertainty i
could tell you what your life will look
like in four years time when you step
outside of the u.s or if you turn that
option down and say doing youtube i
could show you what your life will be
but now because the economy is changing
the growth cycles are changing we don't
have that certainty and i think we need
new types of leaders but people you know
status quo bias prevails and it's nice
to have somebody standing there
you know looking very serious telling us
that things are going to be okay because
they have it in control and for human
beings u-turning and change of minds
aren't signals that someone has it in
control that's interesting um there was
there was an exercise i came across a
couple of years ago called the odyssey
plan
um which is the idea that um you know
it's it's sort of a way of helping you
figure out what to do with your life um
where the idea is that you write down
five years from now what does my life
look like down this current path and
then you put that aside and then you say
okay five years from now what does my
life look like if i take a completely
different path you put that aside and
then you say okay five years from now
what does my life look like if money and
societal obligations are no object and i
could just literally do what i want what
does mother what does my life look like
then and i did this this sort of thing
about two years ago and it really helped
me realize oh i just never spend spend
the time thinking long term well medium
to long term at all and even just
spending half an hour thinking huh if i
go down this current path i'll end up i
don't know in an aesthetic training
program in cambridge being a supervisor
it'll be kind of fun that's what my
day-to-day would look like
that doesn't seem particularly exciting
oh okay maybe i should try something
else and just spending the time to think
about that like really
made me change direction in a way um do
you have any sort of similar practices
or exercises that you that you recommend
for people trying to figure out this
question of like what the hell do i do
with my life
i i mean it's a really good question i
think it again comes back to the task
which sounds really boring so there's
lists in the book of activities that
people do in their occupation and skills
that you might want to hold and i think
it comes back to that i'm thinking about
are you happy to spend your day engaged
in activities like those so a lot of the
jobs that look exciting they look
exciting because on tv they're
glamorized i mean law always is one that
comes into my mind and i think i would
be a terrible lawyer because the
commitment to a day to day that's like
six in the morning to eight in the
evening is absolutely something that you
still need today sadly um but people
don't know about that before they go in
they think about themselves standing in
court and litigating the cases so it's
bringing it back to those kind of boring
humdrum tasks
and i think when it comes to your think
big journey
it's about what were the tasks that i
would be doing in 10 years time how
would i spend my monday morning how
would i spend my tuesday morning and how
can i get myself in a place where that's
really realistic and you know for most
of us
um we won't be able to be in a place
where we don't have to worry about money
so we have to be doing something that
adds value to society but this is an
opportunity to kind of put yourself on a
path
where you get to
do tasks that are as fun as possible and
you're actually enjoying them so you
don't feel like working and i think for
most of us that's our goal right that 70
of our time at work it doesn't feel like
a painful a painful process we're really
enjoying those activities within the
field of behavioral sciences
i get them like a a lot of the stuff you
talk about in the book you talk like at
the end of each chapter there's the sort
of different insights from behavioral
science which are translated into things
that we can do right now one thing that
i was curious about is what does
research in this field look like like
how do we
how do we know that the stuff that we
talk about in the book or the stuff that
you read in a i don't know a self-help
book how do we know that that's actually
legit like what what does the primary
material look like it's a great question
so i mean behavioral science isn't a
discipline so the research can come from
economics psychology anthropology and i
think the big banner that i would put on
it is that it's describing why people
behave the way that they actually do
um so why do people procrastinate
what's the reason that people work more
productively together as teams these are
questions that behavioral scientists
will look at i think the the big
fascination with behavioral science
scientists is causality so
if you were to think about the um the
cover vaccine a lot of the debates about
it are was did do we really have enough
time to put it through field trials in
the same way that other medicines have
actually gone through these rcts
and that's what behavioral science tries
to mimic in the real world so
psychologists will do lab experiments
with students so if you look at the
behavioral science literature a lot of
the kind of early ideas would be from
bringing students into the lab it's not
scary like in the 70s i promise so you
know really easy stuff and looking to
see whether or not we can change their
behavior with a particular insight and
then somebody like me brings those
insights into companies
into policy and asks is the stuff that's
coming out of the students in the lab
actually replicating in companies and a
lot of times it doesn't i would be very
honest with you because obviously when
we have students in the lab we have them
for a very short period of time when i'm
working with workers i want to know
do the change i make work in the moment
one week later one month later 12 months
later and because of that methods are
really important so if you if someone is
listening and wants to pivot towards a
queer behavioral science you know data
science is absolutely your friend in
this regard
and then i think at the top level we
look at macro trends so at the moment
i'm building an index
with citibank that's going to look to
see whether or not we can actually
predict profit and loss based on the
culture that organizations actually have
um and again what we're really going to
have an eye on is is that useful for
institutional investors so we can change
their behavior and can we change
customer behavior so it there's kind of
two things that i want the listeners to
kind of take away one it's about
explaining behavior whether it's at the
lab level
individual level out in the real world
or the macro level and secondly it's
really can we talk about causal effects
are we sure that the change that we made
or are we sure that the analysis that
we've run is really talking about a
direct effect okay yeah i thought the
way that you handled some of these in in
the book was was really like
like often you you see a i don't know
lifehacker.com article about
there's a study that shows that if you
wear red that then you'll perform better
in this thing oh amazing you should
start wearing red and the way you
describe this in the book it's like well
actually um it's it's it's fairly
correlationally not very causationy but
hey maybe there's something there who
knows the evidence isn't quite there but
yeah maybe consider wearing red and i
thought i kind of chuckled when i was
listening to that because i was like
that's a very nice way of describing the
uncertainty that we often have in this
sort of research i am the worst person
to actually get to write a magazine
article because i tend to kind of go
well yes the evidence says this but
maybe it might work for you but i think
that's honest because the populations
that are studied by behavioral
scientists including me
might be different from you so
there's two companies i'm working with
at the moment down in canary wharf
they're right across the road from each
other and one experiment worked
incredibly well in one company and it
did not necessarily it didn't work at
all actually the other company we got
zero like a flatline zero effect um and
that's because context matters and both
of those companies have very different
contexts very different populations they
have their own subcultures and they have
their own pressures and it's the same
for anything that you're read in a
magazine so i i encourage people to be
experimental so they might hear me say
something but they should say actually
you know i maybe grace knows something
about what she's talking about but she
doesn't know me the only person who
knows me is me so i'm going to
experiment with her idea and if it
doesn't work i'm going to throw it out
and that for me is a practice that i
think we should do as individuals for
our health and careers as managers when
we're leading teams and
also in the government you know a
leadership tactic that might work for
boris johnson might not necessarily work
for another leader and unless you're
mindful of that you're going to be
taking on practices that somebody has
given you
that's actually based on evidence that
can't be universal we were
brainstorming what we were going to have
as like the kind of uh intro music spiel
for this podcast oh what did you pick uh
we haven't quite figured it out yet but
like one thing that i was um i i wanted
to say at the end of the intro is you
know
introduce the guest explain what their
credentials are and what we talk about
in the episode
and something to the effect of so um
sit back grab a cup of tea and remember
to take everything you hear with a
sprinkle of salt
because i think like in these sorts of
podcasts that you know you've been on
i've been on where
people are really giving life advice
yeah however you dress it up um giving
life advice
we can only really speak to either our
own personal experiences or in your case
uh evidence from
fairly like not um
soft skill type stuff that it's very
hard to like you know directly measure
like a blood a blood test increasing
it's like more hard science and this is
more soft science
the context matches so much and i think
one thing i want everyone to try and be
mindful of is that like no one has the
guidebook for how to live life you just
gotta sort of try stuff and if it works
for you then great it works for you but
if it doesn't work for you then try
something else and
it sounds like that's generally how you
approach it as well absolutely so be
experimental and i think context matters
are kind of you know two words
to really emphasize if something is
working for me in my environment it
might not necessarily work for other
people and it's also a way of actually
to get to know yourself so if you're
trying something and it's not working
you can think about okay why did it work
for somebody else and not necessarily
for me
and you can have confidence then in kind
of trying other tools without getting
stuck in the same in the same cycle nice
um coming back to the question of goals
one thing uh another thing that i've
been mulling over for several years now
is this balance between
being satisfied with where we're at in
life versus the worst versus striving
for more having like a think a big kind
of goal
how how do you think about that that
balance
i think this i think strivers
don't like the process
so i think if you found
the activities that you enjoy doing on a
day-to-day basis and and they're filling
you up and they're pointing you in a
direction
towards a particular goal then you're
happy doing the process
so the type of striving and the type of
impatience
melts away perhaps not fully because
maybe you're more impatient and you want
to get there quicker than you're going
at the moment
but i think people who really suffer
from striving are people who have a
vision of a me plus
that actually is a bit distorted from
the reality and they're doing lots of
activities now that they don't
particularly enjoy that they're not
particularly find it finding useful so
again i think it's kind of taking a step
back and saying you know why am i
feeling so frustrated with my day-to-day
do i need to rebalance and start doing
some activities that i actually enjoy
that i can really see the clean clear
line of purpose too
in order to make myself feel better now
um and again once you're moving forward
and once you're walking
i think that that's that's good that's
good enough for most people okay yeah i
think like there's
there's a lot of evidence as you know
about how
experiencing progress and i think you
talk about how to like make your
progress more salient experiencing that
sense of progress
really is like extremely fundamentally
satisfying uh and so i guess sometimes
if i think
you know i i i guess the standard straw
man would be like oh well you know if
you just play video games all day then
it's it's fun but it's not like
meaningful i think it's not meaningful
because it's not really progressing you
forward in a way that
adds value to the world is it is that
fair to say
or to yourself so you know some people
who i meet their values are really about
making making money which just which
doesn't bother me um but i think that
they need to be clear on what are the
tasks that they're going to do that add
value to the world i think i think that
i think that's really true and i think
finding the kind of right balance of
pleasure and purpose is really important
you should play video games if that's
something that actually really helps you
relax i think for some people it's been
shown that it can be like mindfulness so
again really thinking about individual
differences if playing mario kart is
what gets you kind of out of the day and
into the moment you should spend time on
that but it's balancing that time so
balance the time between serving
yourself in the present day and also
serving yourself in the future okay and
i guess most people's dream job would be
one where they've got pleasure plus
purpose in the same thing yeah and that
would be great um but if not then some
things are pleasurable and some things
are purposeful and just balancing those
is that is that fair to say absolutely
absolutely and i think as well the kind
of adaptation that we feel as humans
they call it it's called hedonic
adaptation everything that you get
you'll adapt to it really quickly so
whether you get the nicest car whether
you get a pay rise you know the
happiness moments are really fleeting so
if you really are kind of in a place and
you feel that things aren't going your
way trying to draw attention to things
that are going right kind of the small
wins so that you can kind of elongate
the happiness that you'll actually get
from the car from the pay rise um but
also look at those kind of small moments
you know
if you have an interaction today with
somebody and they insult you it would
probably weigh really heavy on you
whereas if somebody gives you a huge
compliment how long do you hold on to
that which is a really interesting thing
for us as humans right that we really
are focused on the negative we're
focused on the losses we're focused on
our slice of ego but we go through our
day and most of us actually have some
like you know really wonderful exchanges
with people we have some nice things
happening to us so drawing attention to
those if you're feeling that you're
striving and you're starting to burn out
hmm yeah it's like with youtube comments
like 99.99 of them are really nice and
you don't think about them and then when
there's one mean one that hits a bit too
close to you and you think about that
for the rest of the day do you read them
i do yeah you read all the comments uh
probably not all the comments yeah
certainly certainly most of them
wow that is good yeah do you
you don't seem to have much of a social
media presence but you've done a lot of
like writing in publications and things
do you get like haters is is that a
thing so recently i wrote um i wrote
something for the ft and it polarized
people
um and they usually turn off the comment
box for kind of articles like the one
that i wrote so it was about managers
and about mediocre managers kind of
holding back people's careers um but it
was really interesting to read those
comments because people either really
loved it
in in a five-star way or they really
hated it and that polarization i think
comes through
a lot on social media but i think it's
imprinted in our society around kind of
political values um around even what
people would like to watch on tv that
we're much more yes or no or all or
nothing than we were in the past and i
think think big is really about kind of
getting people to kind of come into the
center a little bit and kind of say
actually you know you can have
kind of more balance and you can
actually think both in your opinions if
you think about polarization but also in
the choices that you make on a
day-to-day basis
um
so in chapter two chapter two or chapter
three rather um you talk about internal
the internal things that are like either
holding us back or help can can help us
move forward to achieve our think big
goals um one of the concepts which is
interesting is the idea of locus of
control um what is that
so locus of the control is the idea that
there are two types of people in in in a
way of kind of binarizing it there are
people who believe that everything is
within their own control so when
negative events happen to them they take
control of the situation and they try to
move forward in a way so try to find a
side door try to find another entrance
and then there's people with an external
locus of control who believe that
everything happens to them so it's at
the hands of other people um it's at the
hands of the universe in the extreme um
most of us will have both internal and
external looks controlled depending on
our domain so maybe in family life some
people will have internal locus of
control they believe that they can
control everything they feel quite safe
in their family life in the work life
they think their career is happening to
them and i think
again
it isn't all or nothing so getting
people to think about what is it that i
can actually control in this particular
moment
and taking
the choice to take that control so i
think even for people who are having a
really terrible time in toxic workplaces
who are being bullied
there is something that they can
actually control in that moment and
really encouraging them to take that
control to allow them to move forward
rather than just seeing the negative and
just seeing the bad things that are
happening to them with the idea that
they can get out of that situation
um okay how do how do people end up with
internal slash external
loci
we don't know so this and this will come
down in the same way like genetics so
you would have people who believe in
nature and people who believe in nurture
and i think the reality is that it's
probably a combination of both so our
genetics probably give us some
proportion of our locus of control and
when we're born um depending on the kind
of experiences that our ancestors have
had but i think the biggest thing is
going to be the environment that you
actually grew up in so i think if you're
put in an environment where you're
encouraged to make decisions when you're
really young you're encouraged to kind
of choose your own path choose your own
toys in the play box for example that's
going to allow you think that you are
are then more in control of your own
destiny as somebody who has these kind
of really really structured lives and
thinks that everything is coming for
them and i saw a researcher and i can't
think of his name but he's working on
the changes of the generation from
generations where
kids were just left to play so they were
kind of pushed down the road towards
this kind of structured education where
people go to
different sessions at particular times
but their whole day is stacked by their
parents
it does seem to have some influence on
whether or not you think you can
actually control your own destiny those
kind of early moments
that's interesting i guess like so
i feel like i'm i'm quite an internal
locus of controlly type person
but i wonder if that can also go too far
like if
for example i don't know i get rejected
by a girl and i
you know there's an extent to which
it is useful for me to internalize that
as okay
i could have controlled that situation i
did badly therefore what can i learn
from this etc but there's also part of
it that's like well actually there are
a thousand reasons why i've been
rejected by this girl that have nothing
to do with me in the slightest yeah um
and i guess it is about balancing the
two that sometimes it is actually
external factors that have led to
something that completely outside of
your control but let's think about what
are the things we can control and what
can we do differently next time
potentially and i think this is a really
good attitude in decision making so if
you think about
how most people determine whether or not
an outcome is successful they will look
to see did they succeed or fail so do
they get a check box or do they get an x
and in that case for people with the
internals that look controlled as you
pointed out being rejected by a a girl
could be could be this really negative
experience it's hard to rebound from if
you take the behavioral science
perspective or you take kind of good
decision-making kind of one-on-one if
you come to one of my classes you should
be focusing on if you have an outcome
that other people would label success
and fail sitting down and thinking what
did what did i control in that
particular situation what could i have
done differently what was my input and
what was down to luck and in luck i
would put anything that's determined
outside yourself by other by other
people and then it's really about
identifying those things that you can't
control and taking hold of them and not
over obsessing on the stuff that is
outside your
outside your control so in some ways
it's kind of taking the best of the
internal of locus of control recognizing
that luck does play a role in
determining these outcomes of success
and failure and and people who do these
post-mortems really do see learning and
failure but they don't dwell on failure
um so if they have a fa if if they fail
on a particular moment they're sitting
down saying what could i have done
differently and then for the future
they're taking those lessons on board
yeah speak speaking of failure so you
you talk in that chapter about
anticipating failure and how often that
holds people back i wonder if you can
talk like what does that mean to
anticipate failure yes i mean so
anticipation of an event brings on
anxieties
that can be worse than actually
experiencing an event itself
so very often if you talk to people who
report having anxieties or who are
having worries they're talking about
something that might actually happen in
the future rather than something that
they're going through in a particular
moment and anticipated loss of version
is exactly that you know it's been shown
that when i think about what it's like
to not get a promotion
to fluff up if i'm doing some public
speaking um to do something badly
that the kind of how i imagine myself
feeling that sadness is is felt in my
body in in in the way this manifests but
it's much worse than actually going
through it and i think the one thing
about human beings is that we're really
good actually at rebounding
so when we go through negative
experience and we allow ourselves to go
through negative experiences we realize
actually it's not as bad as i thought
there are other options later and we
tend to be very very resilient and when
we're anticipating failure or
anticipating losses we underestimate
that resilience um so some of the kind
of most successful people in our society
are people who have failed a lot because
firstly they're learning from their
failure but secondly you're probably not
going to get very far in life without
experiencing failure right you're going
to have to get rejected so you know on
the daily market it's exactly the same
you're not going to meet probably the
exact person feel with all the people
out in the world if you don't go and
meet some people who are wrong for you
in the beginning it's the same with jobs
so really kind of taking that on board
that actually you're going to do some
things people aren't going to like you
you're going to get negative feedback
it's going to be unfair you're going to
have bad luck but there's learning in
that and you're still on that journey
nice um one
one bit on the book that i liked was
when you referenced the dating market in
terms of i i think it was around
differences in genders between like risk
taking and risk aversion i wonder if you
can kind of
talk about that i would love to test
this so one thing that we know for sure
at the average level is that women do
tend to be um more risk of rest as
compared to men so men are risk-averse
which is less so than women and i have
this theory that men were able to be
rejected much more in early years kind
of when they were learning about whether
failure is acceptable or not because
they have to ask you know women on dates
in most cultures so when you're asking a
girl you know at 12 13 years of age and
they say no to you if you're a disco
that's going to be terrible but actually
you're learning that it's not that bad
so the second time you asked the third
time you asked the fourth time that you
asked you know there will be people who
are actually so resilient to this that
by the time they're 15 16 17 they're not
feeling that failure and we carry that
into other domains in our lives that
there are these positive spillovers so i
think by
having women not necessarily um
represented in competitive sports to the
same degree as men so they're not you
know feeling that they can lose in in
the same way from early life and also
not being the ones to ask i'm hoping
that's changing though i'm hearing that
it is but not being the ones to ask as
often as men that does set the parameter
for risk aggression that economists care
a lot about yeah and i guess when it
comes to even things like
uh asking for a promotion or asking for
a raise
if
if at the average level there's even a
one percent difference in risk aversion
between men and women that at the
extremes is going to translate to a
significant disparity between people who
get promoted and people who don't and
obviously they're it's all
multifactorial but yeah it's it's
interesting how that that you know yeah
theoretically could could be done to
that um i have a bunch of uh female
friends who are currently on the daisy
market and i you know they always like
oh you know i don't like these out yeah
i could never ask a guy out because i'll
get rejected and i'm like come on like
are they on the day are they on dating
like on technology or are they out there
like asking people out on on the street
in the in the way in the u.s oh no
everyone's in the everyone's on the apps
yeah no one ever asks people out on this
well well other than a subset of guys
that are into that sort of thing
it still happens in the us though which
always amaze me yeah people go up to
each other in real life and in real life
no way have always done it so the
technology is just as big as it is here
but that part of the culture hasn't gone
away which i find which i find
fascinating
um have you noticed any other like in in
in terms of like risk aversion
does the data say anything on like kind
of ethnic minorities versus like white
people around like risk taking risk
aversion that kind of stuff yes so um
for countries like the us and the uk
um people of color do tend to be less
risk-averse than white men um and there
we see less risk of us um less sorry
more risk of rate thank you progression
more risk averse as compared to white
men um but the male female divides still
stands there so for example if you were
to compare white women to black men
black men will take more risks as
compared to white women so the gender
the gender dimension trumps but we do
see this kind of interaction effect um
with race and ethnicity um and again it
comes down to i think two things firstly
early childhood experiences but secondly
rejections so
white men are much less likely to be
told no as compared to all other people
so other genders other races and other
ethnicities
and then if you're told no it becomes
rational not to ask again right because
you're getting you're kind of getting
that feedback loop but actually the
reverse is probably true so in some ways
women and people of color should
probably be asking more because the
chances of them then getting a yes is
actually going up and but i think that's
easier said than done so you know
there's a huge literature on societal
backlash particularly for women that
talks about what happens if a woman
actually speaks up and asks for what she
what she wants in work
and steps outside the stereotype and
there tends to be these negative
repercussions so simply asking for more
doesn't necessarily mean that you'll
actually get more um so it is really
really complicated and that's why
in today's society having that having
transparency is really helpful on both
sides it's really helpful for companies
because they can pay attention to
are they allowing you know really
talented individuals fall short
for reasons that have to do with kind of
these embedded stereotypes that they're
not seeing but at the individual level
when we have transparency a lot of the
problems go away
so both for women and people of color
they feel much better saying actually
my salary is in the in the bottom 20
percent but i'm knocking it out of the
park if i compare it to the rest of this
distribution and why is that so the
certainty of having something to
actually point to is really really
powerful so i i really support you know
the gender pay gap reporting and i now
support the kind of the idea that we're
going to move to having race and
ethnicity pay gaps as well
oh interesting so i've i've been looking
a lot into this stuff um now that i have
a team of like 11 people expanding to
20. fantastic um with
you know i've i've had a few
conversations with the team members
around like raises but not as many as i
thought i would have and i think there
is a
i think
because at least in our team it's uh
we're just making stuff up as we go
along so we don't have like a salary
policy or a race policy like how do you
even benchmark when someone is like
writing content for a youtube video or
like a youtube
i don't know um but i want to add in a
level of like transparency where it's
more clear that okay this is this level
of role this is a salary for this level
of role and
you can ask for a raise every i don't
know at the end of every quarter if you
want and here's how like how how should
how how should a small business go about
being more transparent about this stuff
i mean in some ways i think with a small
business because
i'm in the situation with the lc at the
moment where i have a team about the
same size as yours um and i and if if
somebody asks for a raise and they're
successful
i think about who are the people who are
very like them in the group who deserve
a raise as well and i just give it to
them so instead of you know yeah because
i i also review so and i'm only doing it
annually and i think annually is
probably enough to kind of really think
about uh performance so doing it
quarterly is even better i guess um but
i think by doing it annually you give
everybody the same door to come to you
um they can ask for what they want but
then just being mindful who didn't ask
because again you know there's kind of
two things that it's not about
necessarily you being kind of fair or
being seen to be open people might have
had bad experiences in pre-previous jobs
where they don't necessarily feel
willing to speak up and just by saying
i'm doing this every year and then i'm
going to review what i've decided to
give and i might come to people and and
give them raises i think builds trust in
a team at at the smaller level which
will pay dividends which when you scale
which i and i use the word when because
i'm sure you will now that you're not
going to
america so chapter four of the book is
all about time and um you mentioned
something earlier in the conversation
that i wanted to ask you about um you
said behavioral science looks at things
like why do we procrastinate yeah uh
which is a question that i get like
from
every every direction um why why do we
procrastinate
it's a really good question and i think
in some ways by writing about
procrastination i make a rod for my own
back because i am a terrible terrible
terrible procrastinator i think there's
evidence
that procrastination is good
up to a certain point so adam grant has
written about this he's an excellent ted
talk for anyone who's interested um and
kind of the idea of procrastination so
if we think about our thinking styles we
have two thinking styles
very very fast impulsive is where your
habits are built where you're trying to
get your small steps embedded and then
very very slow and very very deliberate
and those classifications are owned to
my own to a man called danny kahneman
and everyone really then came to believe
that actually when you're in the slow
mode of thinking
that you are at your best so you get to
be in flow you get to concentrate on
something but there's an emerging
evidence that when you're in your fast
mode of thinking you have this
unconscious that could be worming away
at a problem that you're trying to solve
so let's imagine that you're trying to
think about what you want to do in five
years time
maybe one of the best things that you
can do is to take your focus off it
and kind of put it to the back of your
mind and some thoughts will actually
come out and i think procrastination is
good in that respect if you're saying
actually i have a really big
challenge at the moment i'm i'm not
feeling creative i'm going to go for a
walk that feels like a procrastination
activity but you take the challenge with
you or some of our best ideas are in the
shower why is that well we're
procrastinating in the show we're
thinking about what we think about the
idea but at the extreme it starts to get
negative when you're putting off tasks
and the deadlines are looming and the
deadlines are looming and you have
nothing to show for it and i think then
the book offers some really good tips
about how to rein that behavior in so
how can you make sure that you're not
you know booking drinks for friends that
you're not putting on netflix that
you're not going for unnecessary walks
that aren't helpful to you when you need
to sit down and actually do the task
yeah one thing i find for myself with
kind of getting over procrastination is
that i think often procrastination is
more of a problem with getting started
than it is with con continuing so kind
of like you know the the law of inertia
newton's first law that if something is
at rest it takes a big push of energy to
move it forward yeah but once it's
moving forward it's like it just
continues to go yeah um uh and so
when i think if i find myself
procrastinating i often just think like
how do i make it as easy as possible for
me to just start doing the thing for
just two minutes because chances are
once i started doing it for two minutes
it will then you know i will then
continue like you know
if if i have a youtube video to film for
a day i'm just like i can't be bothered
to set up the cameras i'll just like get
up i'm just gonna do it for two minutes
just set up a single microphone yeah and
it's like okay well that's in the
microphone i'm here i've got the music
on i might as well just set up the whole
thing i know it's all set up i might as
well sit down and record the video um
but i find that like targeting it to
words just making it as easy as possible
is is how i personally personally do it
um do you have any any hacks or tips on
this well that's a great one so lowering
the cost of actually doing things so you
can liken it when you're
thinking you're somebody who doesn't
like running to putting your running
shoes and your gear out in the in the
nights that you actually slip them on
what you described though really reminds
me of the pomodoro technique that has
been shown to work really well for
procrastinators so the idea that you
don't plan to work for the day you just
show up for 20 minutes
and there's something about our brain
not wanting to have something that
hasn't closed a loop that will keep us
working so pomodoro technique says you
work for 20 minutes and regardless of if
you're in flow you take a five minute
break and when you take that five minute
break you will start worrying and
jiggling and really wanting to actually
go back to the task so the sheer act of
showing up for those first 20 minutes
will get you on the path that you
described
nice um any other tactics that you use
to respect i mean especially when
writing a book i imagine that's like a
reality
i mean i use a thing called i use a
thing called the compromise effect which
has been really shown in marketing so
you know you know that your marketers
are really lazy when they show you three
options for things safe in the knowledge
that you'll actually pick the middle
option so as human beings we don't like
to take the extremes when it comes to
kind of making choices
so i use this for my workload so kind of
in the morning if i'm planning on doing
something like writing where there's a
particular output i'll define what a low
output looks like to find what a medium
output looks like and define what a high
output looks like and regardless of
which one i'll hit i'll mark it off on
my to-do list so i give myself that kind
of satisfaction um and most of the time
and i always say this maybe i'm just an
average person most of the time i hit
medium and i've tried it on some friends
now and they hit this medium output as
well so i think if you're somebody who
has this mammoth task and this really
aligns with chunking right think about
what the outputs would look like beyond
i need to do x dividing x down and
giving yourself a treat at the end of it
so whatever it is for you whether it's
it's you know netflix having a massage
going for a walk going out for dinner
with friends bundling it with something
that's really attractive is another way
to actually get you to get you to the
desk again so
really
our decision making is determined by
costs and benefits in the present moment
you want to lower the costs in the
present moment and you want to make the
benefits as nice as possible and
bundling with good activities helps as
well nice how how do you manage your
to-do list like
yeah it's a great question i mean again
i wake up off my own back by talking
about this but it's my struggles that
has made me write about actually about
writing to-do lists so every day i have
a period of time in the morning where i
do deep work where i do writing where i
do kind of tasks that really really need
to be done
so this morning i was actually preparing
something for the skills committee that
you mentioned um in the beginning um and
then i go about my day
having engagements with people like you
you know kind of having kind of
enjoyable engagements so i really do the
horrible part first and then i have the
nicer part of my day that actually comes
later so it's hard to for me it's hard
to get an appointment with me before 10
and that's because my mornings is for my
is for my deep work at the end of the
evening i do um i look back on how i
spent my day i think about what went
right because i'm really bad for seeing
kind of small wins during the day um and
i'll reflect on each activity and think
about actually do this activity did i
enjoy it at the moment and was it
something that would pay off in the
future and if it's something that's
neither
i try to avoid it or cut it all together
and i write about meetings in my in my
institution that i don't go to a lot of
them now for that exact reason so i find
myself showing up people would talk in
circles about issues
nothing would be resolved we would waste
maybe two hours that could be used on
something that's giving me purpose or
someone else purpose
or giving me fun in the day
okay that's interesting do you do any
sort of weekly review type stuff
yes
every sunday evening i look back at how
i actually spent my time during the week
um and days where things went well and
days where things did not necessarily go
well and then i think about the week
ahead and how i can make it better for
myself so if i've had a particularly
draining week and the activities are
things that i need to show up for that
can include scheduling more free time in
the week going forward so it doesn't
actually always mean about getting more
work done the next week if i felt quite
exhausted and i didn't feel that i was
able to show up um it also can mean that
i think about what are the activities
that i might want to pull out of my
calendar
given my experiences in the last week um
that might not actually be adding value
for anybody um and it also allows me to
think about what are the big things that
i want to check off my list in the week
going forward okay
so i've so i first came across weekly
review stuff like five years ago when i
first read getting things done by david
allen yeah and in that time i've done
about four weekly reviews um
any tips for sticking to this practice
you need to make it easy so i'm not a
journaler yeah so i do all of this on my
phone so i basically have my diary is
set up and i have kind of two columns
that say this was pleasurable this was
purposeful that i just fill in so my
entire journaling on a sunday evening is
15 to 20 minutes
and i think that the the reason that we
fall off the wagon with journaling is if
we're carrying around notebooks we're
carrying around pens it's not really how
how we kind of are set up as a society
anymore and we're thinking that it's
going to take one hour and two hours so
it's really about making it simple and
doing it at a time so i do it sunday
night people who have read think big um
who've reported back are using it on
commutes and using it on times that
otherwise would not necessarily be used
for anything useful
oh okay that's interesting i spent a lot
of time on the toilet scrolling twitter
so maybe like it could be a sunday it's
a sunday toilet time equals weekly
review on my phone keep it simple that
will go viral
[Laughter]
something like that um
what is the effect effect heuristic
so the affect heuristic is all about
emotions right so it basically talks
about when we're in a hot state
um we're feeling emotional so it could
be happiness it could be sadness it
might even be feeling hungry
um we're likely to make decisions that
are based on rules of thumb rather than
good decision making and we're much more
likely to be biased so you know there's
really great research on this that looks
at if you are up in front of a judge all
else equal how does your sentence look
before and after lunch
um if you are pitching for venture
capital what's your likelihood of being
successful all else equal looking at
whether you turned up at the start of
the day you turned up in the middle of
the day you turned up at the end of the
day
and it really has to do with the
emotions of the people who are actually
judging you so
if you think about yourself when we and
the effect heuristic the kind of the
outcome is you should never make a
decision when you're feeling emotional
so if somebody expresses anger towards
you if you're feeling angry towards them
if they're asking you for a decision
park it you know unless you're a surgeon
a firefighter or somebody else who
really needs to spring into action there
is always time for you to take a break
it could be a minute it could be 10
minutes it could be an hour but taking
that time out and then on the other side
if you're facing people who are judging
you
what can you think about their emotions
in in on a particular day that will tip
the odds to your advantage so making
them laugh is is a really good thing
using narrative that actually that
they're likely to remember so making
them feel sad and empathetic towards
what you're trying to sell them is
really really helpful and again avoiding
being before lunch so hunger is
absolutely the worst thing that you want
is somebody who's making a decision on
your on your future oh okay yeah so i'm
uh i'm doing an interview with someone
who's applied for a job with our team
straight after this uh and i'm feeling
kind of hungry now so i should probably
just take us out to lunch and
then we'll do the interview over over a
snack or something that's a good shout
out um
so in chapter five i think you talk
about outside uh well in chapter four
inside chapter five is i think it's
outside like um getting feedback and
judgment and stuff from other people
yeah um
one area in particular that i know a lot
of people struggle with like is
the fear of being judged by others when
doing things like putting themselves out
there or writing a book or starting a
youtube channel does what does
behavioral science say about this thing
of getting over this fear of what other
people think about us is it good that we
worry about what other people think
about us
i think you know it's good
until
it's not which isn't which isn't a very
helpful expression but i think it's good
in the beginning because i think the
kind of anxieties and the nerves that we
feel set us up to do a great job right
so um i think it was mick jagger before
he was going on unconscious to actually
label his nerves or this is the
excitement about me seeing the crowd
rather than actually feeling that the
butterflies in his stomach were anything
negative and reframing it that way can
be can be can be really really helpful
um
i'm actually forgetting your question my
fear of getting uh getting over what
people think about us oh yes so i
as individuals we tend to think people
are looking at us much more often than
they actually are
um and there's a thomas gilovich was the
first to write about this idea of the
spotlight effect and the spotlight
effect basically says that if i fluff up
if i fall down in the street if i do
about public speaking even if i do a
negative youtube and i have lots and
lots of followers the chances of people
remembering are actually really really
low because we're information overloaded
all the time and we're also much more
caught up in ourselves than we are with
other people but even the people who do
remember tend to be much more
sympathetic or neutral than we'll
actually give them credit for so
embracing the spotlight effect and
actually taking action kind of safe from
the knowledge that you know if you do
mess up people probably aren't watching
and if they do they're likely to be
sympathetic
it's a really really good way forward
and i think next to that for people who
are really hampered by
you know kind of the saving face effects
that we i recorded from from an irish
perspective that you know the idea that
it's much worse for me to mess up when
other people are looking i think start
doing things where people who you don't
know won't see you in the beginning and
then you'll get some confidence and be
able to go a bit more global so taking
those small steps rather than staying
stuck is really really important
yeah both of these like tie in really
nicely with like you know when it comes
to starting a youtube channel which is
quite a terrifying thing for a lot of
people i think like when i when i did it
i made like 20 videos before i posted it
on facebook because that was the
audience people that knew me i mean
before then like no one was gonna see it
because i had like three subscribers and
like no one's ever gonna find the videos
um but then
you know the advice i i give to people
when they're really worried that oh what
what will my friends and family think is
that hey they probably won't care
they'll
look at it for 30 seconds and move on
with a day because they've got things to
do would be like you know if your
friends and family are like nice people
they'd be like oh this is kind of cool
they'll love you anyway yeah like
the fear is so much more in our heads in
our imagination than it is than it is in
reality
um your one of your final chapters is
all about environment and things that we
can do in our environment to nudge
ourselves towards kind of making
progress on our on i think big goals i
wonder what tips have you found
personally useful in terms of the way
you set up your environment to help do
things like write a book or like do your
research and things like that well i see
you have the green which is really good
so one of the kind of you know if you're
if you're in a place where you don't
have uh you know easy access to kind of
green spaces bringing green indoors is
really really helpful it's really good
it's really good it's good for oxygen so
yeah so there's a bit a big tick in in
in the environment today but you know
for me i think the biggest thing is is
is digital and really thinking about
what's your relationship like with
technology and is that the biggest time
sinker that you have and then setting up
your environment to make it much easier
for you to switch off from technology
when you need it so you know
my job it would be much harder to do my
job if i didn't have access to
technology so i'm a big proponent of it
i can get information really really
quickly it's very easy for me to digest
lots of academic papers now as well as a
lot of kind of taught leaders
but that said if that's all i do then i
never put any output into the world um
and my worst habit is checking email
for other people it would be twitter
instagram snapchat whatever it is
but thinking about is there a way that
you can change your environment to make
it harder for you because it's all about
cost benefits it can make it harder for
you to check your email to check twitter
to check snapchat
and for me it was actually removing it
from my phone
and removing it from my laptop and
putting it on an old ipad allowing
myself check my emails on an old ipad
that was in a different part of the
house so every time i wanted to check my
emails i had to physically go to that
part of the house and i also set up
pledges that i would only check my
emails twice a day and then move to once
a day
and i will tell you i failed a lot so
you know there would be lunch time where
i would be itching to see is anyone
emailing me what's exciting in my inbox
and i would go and check but it was much
less and i've never been more productive
in the periods of my life when i've
managed to switch off my email entirely
okay
that's a good chat i should
just
understand
about how much time i would save
because often like the stuff like it
doesn't really need a responsibility
and one thing you often say in the book
is you know unless you're a heart
surgeon or the president of some yeah
you really don't need to respond
instantly to people so
and then i think other stuff is easier
so you know thinking about the colors on
on the walls that inspire you thinking
about lighting i mean there's really
good evidence on lighting to suggest if
you're creative you want to have kind of
more dim light if you want to really
focus on something you want to have this
bright light
making sure that you have fresh air in
in your room making sure as well that
you have a place where you go to work so
even if you're somebody who's in a flat
chair that feels overcrowded maybe the
place for you is going to be a seat in a
coffee shop but trying to get that same
seat every day there's something about
our mind when we're in particular
environments that it switches to this is
the activity that i'm supposed to be
doing in this environment um you know
people find that when they go to pubs
for example they find it when they go to
theater those particular habits that
they that they'll follow without knowing
why and you can actually bring that to
your work where are you actually going
to sit down on a day-to-day basis that
when you do
you're you're digitally detoxed so
you're not on email you're not you're
not you're not you're not plugged into
anywhere anywhere else but the work that
you're doing and also that you're not
moving around yeah i found um during
during the pandemic once i'd taken a
break from medicine then i was spending
just loads of time just at home on my
desk and it was a nightmare and then it
was a few months later that i discovered
uh the wework co-working space in
cambridge and then i started kind of
commuting there like 10 minute cycle or
10 minute drive each day and there was
something so nice about having an office
to commute to where in the past i would
have thought oh hey i'm a digital nomad
i work from anywhere i work from home
but actually i really like going to an
office and then just staying there all
day and like getting you know a take
away for lunch and then and then
when i come home it's like i literally
only come home to sleep and that just
massively increased my quality of life
so now i'm trying to find those similar
things especially when it comes to so
i'm i'm trying trying to write a book as
well i've been procrastinating the hell
out of it um but one thing i'm trying to
do is like you know certain mornings
each week will be blocked out no one's
allowed to book anything and i go to a
specific coffee shop same one every day
where that is the only place i will
write book stuff yeah um and we've just
signed a lease on an office where we can
like okay now i can focus on youtube
studio when with youtube stuff when i'm
at that space i guess there's evidence
that this sort of stuff is helpful
absolutely and it's like a switch so
when you sit down in the coffee shop it
would be all about the book when you go
into the office it's just about the
youtube video
i'm i'm really making sure that you
stick to that is very important so i
don't know how many of your listeners
are going to be checking their emails in
bed for example or even playing games in
bed on their phone it's so it's really
really bad for us so thinking about
where's the areas in your house in your
space that you're going to do particular
activities and sticking to that will
absolutely make you more productive and
you've mentioned quality of life
i would be surprised if people
didn't follow what you described um and
didn't see happiness increases
yeah i think with the bedroom thing as
well i think in in why we sleep uh
matthew walker talks about this that's a
great book when your bedroom is just for
sleeping it is easier to sleep and you
get better sleep yeah whereas if your
bedroom is also where you chill on your
laptop and where you work and it might
be nice to take a zoom call from your
bedroom but like you're kind of shafting
yourself yeah in terms of sleep and
again it's really hard you you can
imagine that there might be people who
are listening who are their bedroom is
their space so they're living in in in a
city where their bedroom is just a space
but again in the corner of that there
can be a chair where you physically go
to sit you open your laptop and that's
the trigger for your brain actually now
i check emails but when you're in your
bed that's just for sleeping so even
that small separation is enough to build
really good habits to make you more
productive and happier amazing um i have
a bunch of random quickfire questions uh
well
in that in other questions are quick but
the answers don't don't have to be um
so what if we can just kind of blitz
through those okay i guess question one
is what what advice would you give for
your younger self
i think it would be to to think big
um to take some more steps
first of all i like that i'll leave it
at that that's good
um who's had the biggest influence on
your career
my mom actually so when i think about i
wasn't particularly good at school and i
wasn't a student that was actually meant
to go to university and she was really
adamant that i go to education um and i
studied computer science and i've
pivoted a lot from there but i still use
some of the skills so i still were also
working in data science but without her
i wouldn't have gone anywhere what's
your top tip for someone looking for
success
really embed good habits today that will
serve your version of success in the
future so the small actions that you're
taking today what are you what at this
what are you doing today so you know how
are you spending your time and does that
point you in the direction of success
and if the answer is no change how you
spend your time
just on that note um your own definition
of success um i think often when we
think of like i don't really like the
word success because it's it's so tied
up in societal expectations where like
you know if i really enjoy gardening and
i'm gardening in my backyard
society doesn't consider that successful
unless i enter a gardening competition
and win it like yeah for some reason so
like how
how do you feel about success by
extension how do we figure out what our
own definitions of success are because
it'll vary for different people i
imagine it will vary for different
people and i think if you're somebody
who's in your garden um and you know you
can afford to eat and put a roof over
your head you should keep gardening if
you know if that that that is a
successful life to me you know it's
describing somebody who
um their needs are fulfilled um and
they're also incredibly happy in the
activities that they're doing on a
day-to-day basis and i think that's
really what i would love people to kind
of kind of sit back and think about is
sometimes we're trading off earning you
know a small amount of extra money
relatively speaking um in order to get
very small increases in where we're
actually going in our lives so you want
to be in a place where you're enjoying
the activities you really do you want to
be in a place where you can feel
yourself moving forward because purpose
has been shown in life um to really make
life worth living quite frankly so
people you know once you actually find a
direction to point in but it doesn't
need to be about money and it doesn't
need to be about material things
hmm speaking of money um there's all
that evidence that a lot of listeners
will be familiar with that beyond a
certain amount let's say 75000 or
whatever the different study show
further increases in money don't lead to
further increases in happiness
but then there's another school of
thought and there's a
a an interestingly titled paper that i
think was called something like um
if money doesn't bring happiness then
you're not spending it well enough yeah
where the theory is that like well
actually even beyond that point
you you can use money to buy back your
time
by
outsourcing things that you don't enjoy
doing like i don't know
cleaning the house for example which i
guess you don't really need 75k to do
but yeah
there is an element of
the more money you can spend on doing on
removing the things that you don't like
doing theoretically that could increase
to a
quality of life increase um
as someone who's
presumably done reading into this sort
of research what's what's what what does
the data say about about the money
happiness correlation
so the so if you if you read the
correlations it suggests that anything
over a basic income of about 35 000
pounds sterling in the uk doesn't bring
additional happiness but what it doesn't
do because this is relating essentially
income to happiness is think about
firstly
how many hours is some so it controls
for hours but i've never seen a paper
interact hours with income so thinking
about how many hours am i actually
working to get that extra you know that
extra pound which obviously if i'm
working 80 hours a week it's going to be
very happy for me to be um happy in the
moment but the second thing that she did
doesn't do which is a big mistake is it
doesn't talk about happiness over the
life course
so people who are retired get very happy
but again it's depending on how much
income that they actually have in the
opposite direction
so i think you need to think about
what does happiness look for you over
the life course there's going to be
times in your life where you'll need to
do some
difficult things in order to secure
particular life course destinations so
if you're somebody who wanted to be a
surgeon i would imagine it's really hard
for those training for the for the years
and actually even the job itself is
going to have particular pinch points
where there's going to be very very very
high demand but for some people where
that's their passion is going to be
absolutely worth it um and i think
that's the trade-off that doesn't come
true in the literature so the snazzy
headlines the same money doesn't buy
happiness don't take into account hours
worked and they don't take into account
kind of smoothing things over the life
course
how do you how do you think about money
personally like you've written a book
presumably you get royalties from it
you've got you've got other things going
on you do speaking at corporate events
where i've heard they pay like stupid
prices to get someone to give a talk
what what's what does that look like for
you so i think i mean if i was thinking
about one of my values i'm definitely
somebody who wants to earn a decent
living yeah um but i
i will only do that if i'm engaged in
tasks that i actually really like doing
so i turn down things that are quite
lucrative relatively regularly because i
know and i've got caught up in a project
before that that that is like this when
i'm doing it i'm just miserable and i
can't wait to hand it over um so again
what i'm trying to do at the moment is
think about how can i shift my tasks so
that i'm i'm really enjoying doing them
i'm giving them i'm giving back to
society but at the same time it affords
me to actually you know kind of increase
my income as i get older
and i guess you know for
listeners who are
beyond the point of
having their basic needs met yeah then
it's easy enough to be like okay cool
i'm going to turn down things that i
don't like doing yes but for someone
who's not at that point yet
they're like
i i i guess we often do have to do
things that we don't necessarily like to
make money to make ends meet to get to
that point yes um if for someone who's
in that position any any advice on kind
of keep keeping that going in order to
get to the point where then you've got
the freedom to kind of do what you want
yeah so i think for every activity i
mean i did some i did some really crummy
jobs when i was in university and i i
did some other kind of crummy projects
after that but i think focusing on the
skills that they're bringing you in the
moment is really important
um and focusing on how you can actually
make turn it into another opportunity
after the event i think is important as
well and again knowing what you're
aiming for so i think if it's somebody
who's you know working to pay bills to
go to university
it's a really linear path i think if
it's somebody who is doing a particular
job today and it doesn't quite fit with
their future self they will need to kind
of take a step back and say what are the
skills that i'm learning from this what
are the activities that i'm
getting practice of that i can actually
write a cv for the person that i want to
be in five years time um and really
focusing in on leveraging what you're
doing now now for the future but there
will always be i think if you want to
have particularly kind of a professional
career where there's going to be kind of
credentials that are barriers to entry
there will be some pain on
on the journey
and i guess you just have to either
learn to enjoy the pain or just kind of
get over it you do but i think as well
it's always the i mean try try and think
about what's the combination that you
can that you can it doesn't need to be
all or nothing so if you're doing a
particular course to get a credential
hopefully 40 of it is all that's
miserable and there's 60 of it that you
can actually enjoy yeah and focusing on
that part as well so when you do turn up
for the parts that are painful think
about actually i'm going to be doing
something that's quite nice later yeah
and i think even for the bits that are
painful like you know a big chunk of
medical school people don't particularly
enjoy studying for exams but you know
setting up the environment right doing
it with friends having music in the
background even if theoretically
starting with music like slightly
decreases your memory who cares it makes
it more fun so i think there are lots of
sort of fun levers that we can pull even
for things that are miserable um
that in in some way help make things
less painful and a little bit more fun
absolutely and again there's lots of
skills that people can learn for free on
the internet kind of getting out there
if the job doesn't lend themselves in
the direction they want to go
taking those steps to acquire new skills
i think it's really worth doing you know
i've hired people who haven't fit the
box of what somebody would particularly
look like in the role and it's worked
out incredibly well for me and i think
more and more employers are starting to
do that so just because you haven't gone
you know to university that you haven't
taken traditional paths doesn't mean
that you can't succeed in the career
that you actually want
nice um moving on to our quick
questions um what does the first and
last hour of your day look like
so my first hour is having a cup of tea
and standing in my garden now that i
actually have green space which i really
enjoy um as early as i can actually make
it up and my second is unwinding from
everything and
potentially reading fiction but usually
non-fiction okay what kind of fiction
slash nonfiction do you enjoy so the
non-fiction is exactly what you might
expect so it's um kind of organizational
psychology behavioral science i do like
a good kind of crime novel like
white-collar crime so thinking about who
brought down ex-bank at a particular
moment in time
but again kind of really written from a
kind of rigorous fact point of view
fiction it can be anything so i tend to
read popular fiction i have richard
ostman's book someone said to me that
i'm going to try uh reading which is
number one at the moment which is meant
to be quite nice very light fiction like
what i do read fiction anything in
particular you'd recommend
so his first book was very good the
thursday morning club which people might
have might might have heard heard of um
and the second one is meant to be really
good so i'm looking forward to starting
it amazing here we go i'm big on uh
fantasy fantasy fiction when i was
younger i love fantasy i i haven't read
it in a while oh i would recommend have
you come across brandon sanderson no oh
he's my he's
he's overtaking jacob rolling to become
my favorite author of all time wow like
i for sort of
i i anytime i've recommended a brandon
sanderson to a friend that they have
gone down the rabbit hole of his books
and have like it's a series with the
same characters yeah it's so so he's got
a bunch of different series um which
have the same characters but then all of
the series are set in this wider like
marvel cinematic universe type thing
where they kind of interact with each
other and he's got this like
20 30 year plan for all the books that
are going to come out over the next like
30 years where they'll all aware stuff
is being foreshadowed in a book that was
released this year that's going to
become relevant 25 years from now so
it's like a whole lifetime of like
incredible fiction i would recommend
anyway what material item of like
reasonable cost do you think is that
that has has added a lot of value to
your life oh and my apple products okay
yeah they have i mean value in the sense
of speeding up my work and making me
much more efficient absolutely nice
my garden furniture though for relaxing
if i was to pick something up just for
pleasure are we talking hammock are we
talking like chairs like it's a couch
with a table and then some stools around
so it can fit like maybe 10 people um
but in the morning it's just really nice
to be able to kind of just get out get
out in the air actually yeah play what
book would you recommend to everyone
i can't recommend them other than other
than your own which we're going to be
recommending extensively anyway that's a
really um that's a good question so i i
would recommend and think again by adam
grant so it's all about unlearning yeah
and so thinking about what are the
habits or the preconceptions that you
might actually have that aren't serving
you well um and and really spending time
to kind of unlearn them so most of us
kind of go through our lives with a
particular viewpoint and it's trying to
get you to take a step back and think
about what might it be about my
viewpoint that isn't serving me well and
how can i actually enhance my life and
it really ties the idea actually of
having what i would call a diverse
boardroom so
thinking about who you get advice from
on a particular
on on things that actually crop up in
your life and are they very like you so
are they the same age or do they go to
the same university
do they vote in the same political way
um and broadening that boardroom to have
more people who are different to you in
it and and there's two reasons for that
so firstly you're less likely to succumb
to confirmation bias to be told that
you're right all the time which is good
for us but diverse boardrooms will see
opportunities that you don't see
nice um so yes if you don't have a trump
supporter in your in your boardroom you
go get a trump supporter and if you
don't have a biden supporter you go get
a biden supporter for all the us at u.s
listeners
um
this is a question we usually ask um
like uh entrepreneur type people which
is that like if if you lost all your
money if you lost all your business what
like what would you be doing but i guess
for you the equivalent is like if you
got cancelled and you know
because yeah you know it's unacceptable
that you said that thing 10 years ago or
whatever yeah what
but but you still have the same skills
um what would you be doing
i think i'd be writing and putting more
stuff out there so i think we can we
started in you know i'm not on social
media because i'm somebody who detests
social media i just don't have the time
at the moment but i think it's a really
good outlet to kind of reach audiences
that i otherwise would not necessarily
get to meet and i think i will be
writing much more content for for online
already established online mediums but
maybe doing something more myself okay
interesting um what quote or mantra do
you live by if any oh that's a really
good one i have so many of them um
[Music]
i think so it's really about taking
control what you can control and letting
the rest go
very nice i guess a final question um a
journey or destination
journey has to be journey
amazing and that's the title of the
final chapter of your book which is like
two pages long yes why why did why did
he call it journey
because i think you're never done so i
think you know these days
careers are going to go on probably i
mean if you're lucky you'll be 75 and
still doing something so you might have
wound down but you know you'll still be
engaged you'll still be kind of getting
out there meeting people and i think the
ultimate idea that we find a job and
that's the end of it for us is kind of
gone it's gone because the economy is
changing it's being shaped by
technological forces but i think it's
better for us to think of it as a
journey very nice cool yeah
thank you ali pleasure thank you so much